Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschöpfe führen.
Wenn Sie Fragen haben oder etwas nicht verstehen, können Sie mir die sehr desehrt stellen.
Ich werde jetzt ein paar persönlichen Fragen stellen und dann gleich so in den aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen.
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Fritz Müller.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen und Nachnamen langsam unter dem Buch stabilieren?
Mein Vornamen ist F. Friedrich R. Richard. I. Ida. T. T. Teodor. Z. Gi. Zeppeli.
Mein Nachname ist M. W. Martha. I. I. L. W. Ludwig. I. I. E. E. R. Richard.
Danke schön.
Wie alt sind Sie?
60 Jahre alt.
60.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 3. September 1965.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie aktuell?
Ich bin ungefähr 1,75 m groß und ich fiege circa 90 kg.
20 kg.
1 m, 7.
75.
Okay.
Was kann ich für Sie tun, Herr Müller?
Ich kann mich heute zuhören, weil ich plötzlich heute Luftrohr bekommen habe.
Das macht mir sehr starke Sorge. Ich kann schlecht atmen.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Bescheuere?
Seit ungefähr 6 Stunden.
Umgefer?
6 Stunden.
Okay.
Haben Sie Luftnot und Atemnot, oder?
Luftnot und Atemnot ist gleich.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Beschwerden?
Verstübte Beschwerden oder irgendwelche Körperregion Beschwerden?
Ich habe ein bisschen Brustschmerzen und ich bin sehr unruhig.
Okay.
Haben Sie enge Gefühle oder Herzrasen?
Herzrasen ein wenig, aber ich habe auch ein bisschen Brustschmerzen.
Wo genau ist Ihre Schmerzen?
Können wir ein bisschen genau beschreiben?
Brust und Rücken.
Der Brust und auf den Rücken.
Okay.
Kommst du gerade in der Schmerz irgendwo hin?
Nein.
Ganz Brust, oder?
Ja, ganz Brust.
Okay.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 10 einschätzen?
1 leichter Schmerzen und 10 unerträglich Schmerzen entspricht?
6, 7 ungefähr.
Okay.
Könnten Sie mir ein bisschen genau Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie eher dumpf, druckend, brennend oder?
Die sind ja so stechend und druckend.
Druckend.
Und stechend.
Okay.
Ich habe heute auch einmal Blut gespuckt.
Haben Sie Schluckprobleme?
Nein.
Ich habe heute auch einmal Blut gespuckt.
Blut gespuckt?
Ja.
Sind die Schmerzen plötsil aufgete, oder standen Sie eher langsam?
Zuerst war die Luftnot da.
Die Schmerzen kamen später.
Okay.
Und gibt es bestimmte Auslöse für die Beschwerden oder die Schmerzen?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Ich habe keine Auslöse gehabt.
Gibt es keine Auslöse, wie Sie können sagen?
Ich habe die erst seit 6 Stunden.
Haben Sie höchstens?
Ja, ein wenig.
Ich habe ein wenig.
Haben Sie höchstens?
Ja, ein wenig.
Ich habe gesagt, ich habe heute Blut gespuckt, ich habe geustet.
Mhm.
Und wie gesagt, ihr höchstens mit Auslöse oder trocken?
Mit trocken normalerweise.
Aber heute war auch ein bisschen Blut dabei.
Mhm.
Sie haben im Höchsten Blut bemerkt?
Einmal oder mehrere?
Ja, zwei, drei Mal.
Okay, habe ich standen.
Hatten Sie solche Beschwerden schon einmal oder ist das das erste Mal?
Das erste Mal.
Okay.
Ich würde Ihnen jetzt einige Fragen in Ihrem allgemeinen Zustand stellen.
Vermehrung.
Haben Sie, übrigens, haben Sie viel über Ubelkeit erbrechen?
Nein, ich habe viel über Ubelkeit nicht.
Okay.
Schweißausbruch oder nach Schweiß vielleicht Stoffrost?
Nein.
Ich habe keine Probleme mit der Beschwerde.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Nein.
Ein Problem ist gut.
Ja, das freut mich.
Und schlafen Sie gut?
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten, einen zu schlafen oder durch zu schlafen?
Ich habe bisher keine Probleme mit dem.
Nur Ihre Beschwerden seit sechs Stunden.
Okay.
Und wie Ihr es repetit normalerweise?
Ihr meines letzten Seiten.
Sehr gut.
Ja, in meine letzte Seite haben Sie ab oder zurückgenommen?
Nein, gleich schon.
Okay, gut.
Jetzt würde ich gerne nach Vorherkrankungen fragen.
Herr Müller, leiten Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ich leite an Bluthochdruck.
Und ich habe Kamfwader.
Okay.
Und gibt es nur oder bestellt es?
Das reicht schon.
Sind Sie früher schon einmal OP?
Nein, ich habe noch nie OP.
Nein, okay.
Sie haben Bluthochdruck.
Ich vermute, nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein, oder?
Richtig, ja.
Welche Medikamente und welche Dresieren können Sie mir...
Ich stimme alle die Penalton, fünf Millilion.
Morgen?
Morgen, einmal.
Und gibt es nur bei Bedarf oder gelegentlich?
Haben Sie Medikamente ein?
Normalerweise nicht.
Haben Sie Allergien oder Unfältigkeiten, Herr Müller?
Nein, gar keine.
Gut.
Jetzt würde ich gerne nach Ihrer Lebensgewohnlichkeit fragen.
Darf ich fragen, ob Sie rauchen?
Ich rauche ja.
Wie viel Zigaret und seit wann rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche schon seit über 20 Jahren, 30 Jahren sogar.
Ich rauche über seit 30 Jahren und ich rauche ungefähr eine Packung am Tag.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein, gar kein Zelt.
Was meinen Sie zum Beispiel, am Wochenende oder...?
3-mal im Jahr.
Okay.
Nennen Sie bitte persönlich, dass Sie eine Routine-Frage hatten, oder haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein.
Sehr gut.
Jetzt...
Lustig.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet, Herr Müller?
Ich habe eine Frau.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, gar keine.
Ja, keine Kinder.
Was machen Sie vom Beruf?
Was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Alkawi-Fahrer.
Okay, verheiratet.
Und in der Familie in der Nese gibt es wichtige oder bekannte Erkrankungen bei Ihren Eltern und bei Ihren Geschwister.
Wir haben alle Bluthochdruck und alle haben auch Zucker.
Beides.
Ja, beide haben Bluthochdruck und Zucker.
Ja, natürlich.
Leben Sie noch, oder?
Nein, beide verstanden.
Beides verstanden?
Ja, beide verstanden.
Okay.
Mein helles Erweiter.
Schon lange her.
Schon lange her, dass Sie gestorben sind.
Okay, okay.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe einen Bruder.
Bruder.
Ist er gesund, oder?
Der hat auch Bluthochdruck.
Oh, okay.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft, ja?
Gegen Covid-19 und Tetanus oder andere?
Ich denke schon, ja.
Aber gegen Covid habe ich mich diese nicht impfen lassen.
Covid? Sie haben nicht erinnert, oder?
Nein, ich habe mich nicht impfen lassen.
Okay.
Und waren Sie in letzter Zeit, ich meine in letzter 6 Monaten,
oder 5 Monaten im Ausland bzw. in den Tropen?
Nein, weiß ich nicht.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Nein.
Und meine letzte Frage, haben Sie Haustiere?
Ich habe keine Haustiere, nein.
Okay.
Ja, gut Herr Müller.
Sie haben seit 6 Stunden Luftnot und Brust schmessen.
Sie haben gesagt und höften, oder?
Richtig.
Ihre Politik verstanden?
Ja.
Und manchmal haben Sie Haustiere bemerkt?
Richtig.
Ja.
Und andere, Sie haben keine Beschwerden.
Das ist alles, oder?
Ich habe gemerkt, heute ich habe den Blutdruck gemessen.
Der war sehr niedrig.
Ja.
Okay.
Normalerweise habe ich mal hohen Blutdruck,
aber der war heute sehr niedrig.
Okay.
Aber Sie nehmen Ihre Medikamente regelmäßig, oder?
Ja, jeden Morgen.
Jeden Morgen.
Und wie hoch Ihr Blutdruck ist?
Ich habe den vor 2 Stunden gemessen, der war bei 90 zu 60.
Okay, 90 zu 60.
Mhm.
Und Sie haben keine Erbrechen.
Ich habe keine Erbrechen.
Aber Sie haben im Hüsten und Blut bemerkt, oder?
Richtig.
Okay.
Wir sind mit Analyse fertig.
Ich glaube, dass ich alle wichtige Informationen habe.
Und möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder fragen?
Ist das etwas Schlimmes, das ich habe?
Hab ich einen Herzinfarkt?
Ein Herzinfarkt, Sie haben keine Engegefühle.
Und Sie haben natürlich ohne Aufstrahlung Schmerzen.
Aber kann man ihn sein, natürlich.
Und wir müssen ausführlich herköpferlich untersuchen.
Und wir müssen ein paar andere Unterhörungen durchführen.
Natürlich kann man ihn sein.
Aber wir machen das alles.
Kann ich sterben?
Ist das gefährlich?
Machen Sie sich keine Sorge.
Sie sind in der Krankenhaus.
Wir haben viele Erfahrungen.
Und Sie sind in guten Händen.
Wir machen das Beste für Sie.
Aber natürlich, ihr habt gesagt,
müssen wir so nächstes Mal,
wenn Sie sich nicht mehr auf die Hand haben,
dann müssen wir so nächstes Mal,
dann machen Sie das Beste für Sie.
Okay.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Ja.
Framula, hatten Sie in letzter Zeit.
Herr Müller.
Herr Müller, entschuldigung.
Framula, hatten Sie in letzter Zeit eine lange Reise,
zum Beispiel mit dem Flugzeug oder Auto?
Nein, aber ich bin hier Lkw-Fahrer.
Ich hatte in der letzten Zeit eine sehr lange Reise
von München aus bis hierhin.
Okay, das reicht dann.
Danke.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Herr Müller, Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben Krampader.
Sie haben in der letzten Zeit etwas geschwollene oder
umwärmte Beine aufgefallen?
Ja, das Bein wurde sonst ein bisschen dicker geworden.
Okay.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Können wir erst mal eine Spiegel brennen?
Nein, aber wenn wir eine Spiegel brennen,
dann machen wir eine Spiegel.
können wir sprechen.
Okay.
Angumian.
Minotitotens, aber ein bisschen.
Ja, ein bisschen.
Versuchen Sie.
Ja, bitte.
Hier, bitte schön.
Sie sind im Notfallarzt und deswegen diese Patientin,
eine Notfallpatient und müssen wir eine Unterberation machen.
Patient immer wieder gesagt, eine Blut gespuckt und deswegen
müssen wir diese Blut druck und so weiter eine Notfalltischung.
Ja.
Okay.
Dann können wir das Anrund am Gespräch unterbrechen.
Direkt können wir unterbrechen oder nach der Schmerz oder
einem Nese.
Normalerweise sagt der Patient, ich habe Luftnot.
Mir geht es nicht gut.
Ich bin unruhig, habe Großschmerzen.
Da müssten Sie eigentlich sofort ein EKG schreiben und
Vitatparameter messen sofort.
Der kann einen Stemi haben, also einen Herzinfarkt und da
müssen Sie sofort reagieren.
Da können Sie nicht lange warten.
Können wir eh Schmerz-Rückie empfehlen?
Der Patient heißt auf instabiles.
Er hat gesagt, ich habe nicht den Blutdruck.
Ich habe Großschmerzen, ich habe Luftnot.
Mir ist nicht gut.
Es ist unruhig.
Ich habe Blut gespuckt.
Da muss man dran denken, dass der Patient instabil sein kann
und jederzeit sein Bewusstsein verlieren kann.
Entschuldigung, unterbrechen für nur EKG, Vitatparameter oder
auch Ekokardiografie oder Sitalis?
Die Äschö brauchen Sie nicht.
EKG ist wichtig.
Sauerstoffensättigung, Blutdruck, Herzfrequenz, das ist
wichtig.
Ob der Patient stabiles oder instabil ist.
Okay, danke.
Der Patient sagt, er hat Herzrasen.
Das ist wichtig.
Das müssen Sie direkt kontrollieren.
Sofort.
Da können Sie nicht halbe Stunde warten.
Können wir direkt Schmerz-Rückie anfangen?
Nein.
Der hat die Kontrauffang, was er hat.
Wenn er ein Stemie hat, ja.
Aber wenn er kein Stemie hat, er ist mal nicht.
Und auch Schmerz-Interstate ist nicht zu erhöht.
Das ist 6,7, hat er gesagt.
6,7.
Das ist erträglich wahr.
So, fangen wir an.
Ja, ja.
Ich werde anfangen.
Schönen guten Tag, Herr Oberlitz.
Ich habe einen neuen Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich möchte Ihnen diesen Patientin vorstellen.
Ja, das würde ich schon.
Guten Tag.
Danke schön.
Es handelt sich um eine 60-jährige Patientin,
Herr Fritz Müller, 1,75 mG,
und circa 90 kg schwer.
Der Patient stellte sich heute bei uns,
wegen uns seit 6 Stunden,
Dispne und Tachikardie.
Und es ist vor.
Und Thoracalgy.
Der Patient berichtete,
dass die Schmessen keine irgendwo in der Region ausstrahlen.
Ganz Brutz, ganz Thoracal Schmessen,
der Patient hat Schmessen.
Die Schmessenintensität würde laut seinen Angaben
mit 6 von 10 auf einer Schmesskala bewertet.
Die Schmessen seien eher plötzlich aufgetreten
und hatten sie im Verlauf immer schlimmer.
Der Patient gab das Schmerz dauerhaft.
Und außerdem berichtete der Patient,
dass er früher enliche Beschwerden nicht gehabt habe.
Es ist das erste Mal.
Und da oben hinaus klagte der Patient über
Tusis in besonderes Mitpol, Blut.
Der Patient hat Bemäxt.
Wie nennt man das?
Wie nennt man das? Tusis mit Blut.
Ja, wie nennt man das? Ah, dein andern Namen?
Hemptusin.
Nein, Hemoptusen.
Hemoptusen.
Und die Fragen nach Neu-Iseur, Fieber,
Emesis oder Hyperhydroze,
wurden erfährt, nein.
Die Meditativ-Anamnese ist unauffällig.
Und an Vorerkrankungen leidet der Patient
Arteriehypertone und Varikoses.
Und vorerkrankungen,
die bisher noch nie operiert wurden.
Und der Patient nimmt am Lodipin 50 Gramm morgens.
Herr Müller hat keine Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten.
Er raucht Siguratz.
Er hat die Meditativ-Anamnese seit 30 Jahren.
Und entschiebt 30 Packungsjahre.
Der Patient trinkt selten oder ab und zu Alkohol.
Er ist unauffällig.
Und der Patient ist verheiratet.
Er hat keine Kinder.
Er arbeitet als Lkw-Fahrer.
Und in der Familienanamnese,
der Vater des Patients und die Mutter des Patients,
sind an Arteriehypertone und Diabismilitus.
Sind gestorben, beides.
Und der Patient hat einen Bruder.
Er leidet an.
Sind die Eltern an Diabetes gestorben?
Oder wissen sie das nicht?
Ja, ich habe nicht gefragt.
Aber bei Unterhörersohn kann ich fragen.
Ja, ich weiß nur, sie leidet an Arteriehypertone.
Diabetes-Militus.
Und der Patient hat einen Bruder.
Er leidet auch an Arteriehypertone.
Und der Patient ist vollständig.
Und in letzter Zeit war er nicht im Ausland.
Ja, das kann ich alles sagen.
Was hat dieser Patient?
Was kaum für eine Diagnose?
Ja, ich vermute,
unter den anerbändischen Angaben
hat er am ersten auch einen Pummeler-Embulif hin.
Und differenziell diagnostisch kommen
für eine Mönche oder für eine Infizienz in Betracht.
Ja, da wird er aber kein Blutspucken.
Ja.
Also, der Lungenembuddi ist wahrscheinlich die Diagnose,
er hat niedrigen Blutdruck,
er hat Brustschmerzen, er hat plötzlich Luftnot,
er hat eine Unterschenkelschwellung,
er hat Hemoptysen,
er hat eine Ohrherzfrequenz.
Ja, ja, das ist eine Sprit dafür.
Diese Symptome, das ist eine Sprit dafür.
Aber er könnte auch eine akute Blutung haben
aufgrund eines Brunchialkarts in uns.
Könnte auch sein.
Ja, okay, differenziell Diagnose,
wir können sagen,
vielleicht mal die Oliwes-Sendromo in Betracht.
Ich würde er, glaube ich, erbrechen.
Erbrechen, ja.
Ich muss dann mal melden,
weil er brechen.
Ja, ich stimme Ihnen so.
Der Patient ist keine MS.
Und vielleicht die Französisch Diagnose,
wir können sagen.
Was machen wir mit dem Patienten?
Dem geht es nicht gut.
Ja, natürlich.
Und meine Verdacht Diagnose so bestätigen,
würde ich einige Massnahmen durchführen.
Natürlich, als erste Massnahme,
würde ich den Patienten
aus für die körpellische Untersuchung
und Vitalparameter messen.
Atemfreakanz, Herzfreakanz
und Sauerstoffzertigung
und Körpertemperatur messen.
Und Blutdruck natürlich messen,
als Vitalparameter.
Und zur weiteren Erklärung
vielleicht eine
eine operative Unterrichtung durchführen.
Und beispielsweise
Sonografie-Tanisage.
Und Bronchoscopy,
vielleicht ja, keine Seite.
Ne, bringt Ihnen gar nichts.
Bronchoscopy,
sollten Sie auch nicht machen?
Können Sie nicht machen.
Der Patient ist ein Notfall.
Und er kann es nicht.
Ja, ich kann es nicht.
Bronchoscopy ist aktuell kontrainitiert.
Bronchoscopy bringt gar nichts.
Was machen wir mit dem Patienten?
Wir haben den Verdacht einer Lungenemboole, richtig?
Ja, ja, in meiner Verletzung.
Was müssen wir machen?
Ganz schnell.
Ja, ich muss sofort einen Zugang legen.
Ja, sowieso.
Und Anticoagulation, Therapie.
Auch, ja, auch.
Ja, auch.
Ja, Pferda-Berechen, Hepatitis-Aktion, können wir sagen.
Und andere.
Sie wollen die Diagnose erst mal bestätigen, okay?
Ja, der kann ja auch einen Herzinfarkt haben.
Wissen wir noch nicht, richtig?
Ja, ja.
Und der Scheid ist zwischen Herzinfarkt und Lungenemboole.
Ja, ich kann geschrieben und Blut abnehmen.
Natürlich, Entzündung, Parameter, Troponin,
vielleicht CK, CKMV, durchschören.
Was läuft für eine Lungenemboole, welche Parameter?
Ekokal...
Dedimaere.
Ja, Dedima ist wichtig.
Ich habe vergessen, natürlich, Sie haben Red.
Und für Herzkrankheit, Ekokardografie können wir veranstalten.
Nicht für Herzkrankheit, sondern eher für Rechtsherzbelastung.
Bei der Lungenemboole haben Sie Rechtsherzbelastung zeichnen.
Rechte, wenn Trigel, ist erweitert.
Ja, ja, Red.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Eine Lungenemboole, akut, diagnostizieren.
Und wichtig ist, bei einer Lungenemboole
müsste man so schnell wie möglich, weil der Patient ist instabil,
eine systemische Lüse machen.
Eine Lüsetherapie.
Was ist es? Eine Lüsetherapie.
Lüstrepie, ich kenne nicht nein.
Man muss das Blut komplett dünn machen, mit Lüse.
Ich gebe eine Trombolüse.
Trombolüse, ja.
Antihagregan oder Antikwaglan, ich habe gesagt, aber nicht.
Ja, nicht Antik, das ist nicht Makumar oder Varvarene,
sondern sie müssen systemische Lüse mit Streptikinase,
RTPA so etwas machen.
Ah, okay.
Das ist ganz wichtig bei so einem Patienten,
weil dieser Patient ist instabil und der braucht Sauerstoff.
Wir müssen eine Sauerstoff-Setkigung messen.
Sauerstoff-Setkigung, ja, natürlich, ja.
Ganz wichtig, ja.
Aber natürlich müssen Sie vorher einen Herzinfarkt ausschließen,
damit Sie nicht blüsieren.
Das wäre nicht falsch, aber das wäre erstmal der andere Ansatz.
Ja.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Und natürlich werde ich
ein kardiologisches Konzil anfangen.
Und...
Der Patient muss intensiv medizinisch überwacht werden.
Ja, intensiv.
Der muss auf die Intensivstation.
Ja, ja, natürlich.
Weil er ist akut gefährdet.
Ja, der ist lebens-betrollig.
Ja, die Situation ist lebens-betrollig.
Und wir müssen sofort
die Intensivstation aufgenommen.
Ganz genau.
Danke schön.